what was your annual salary as a
gardener between 1 and 2 Grand a month
and you're making 4 grand a month and
you've got another deal that's going to
make you a lot more than that I mean
with these big places but taking massive
risk it's kind of like highrisk high
reward how hard do you work now compared
to how hard you did work when you were a
gardener I don't really work much at all
now to be honest with how much rent are
you paying for that 7 Grand but we're
charging about a grand tonight for that
how do they feel knowing that you're
making so much profit from their
[Music]
house what's happening folks welcome
back to winners on Wednesday I'm sat
here with a guy called Max Baker he
became financially free was a gardener
became financially free from one
property it is a mansion he doesn't own
it but he will own it and he's making
him £3,000 a month and he secured it
with zero of his own money is that fair
to say uh 4,000 a month but yeah four
grand a month there we go well welcome
to winners on a Wednesday thank you for
having me so the reason I wanted to get
you on the show and pick your brains
because you were starting out you a
gardener very nervous about even coming
to the crash course
social anxiety through the roof in fact
I had to drag you to come on the show
because your anxiety was spiking but
you've quit your job you stopped
gardening making four grand a month and
it's pretty passive yeah it's pretty
passive I make the most of the house and
just go there myself when it's not
booked up so it's kind of Best of Both
words you get to stay there yourself
it's got a hot tub all that sort of
stuff so you make the most of it how
much is the house worth this one is
probably 700 800 around that sort of
Mark £700,000 yeah 750 to800 what and is
that the first one that you secured uh
that isn't the first one I secured but
it's the first one we've got at the
moment yeah yeah so we took on a two bed
apartment in Brighton a few months ago
and um that was doing about two and a
half Grand a month two grand a month so
I thought right I'm quitting my job now
cuz that's what I've got into the
training yeah quit my job was doing
really well and then two three months
later there was a head leas restriction
which just threw us all the window sort
of thing so we had to just give the
place back and stuff like that which was
horrible that's awful that should never
happen yeah so you lost your first deal
we're going to go into the detail of
that because if people are watching this
and they go out and get deals definitely
and that's the thing there are things
that can go wrong and you can prevent
that and you can prevent losing money
but you need to be aware of the pitfalls
as well as the opportunity definitely so
you had a bunch of nonsense with that
first deal yeah and you'd quit your job
how did you feel then if you'd quit your
job because you had a deal but then it
fell through then presumably you then
had zero income I was crapping myself a
bit to be honest with you but then we
just thought right now this next few
weeks we're just going to focus and just
hit the phone hit the phone hit the
phone yeah and then uh we stumbled
across this deal actually it was towards
the end when I started to get a bit
depressed and like I think I'm just
going back to work I can't do it and
then G again almost yeah literally so I
literally messaged one person on open
rent didn't even ring them anything and
they had a viewing the next day and I
was there for about 3 hours at the view
and probably looked around the house for
like 5 minutes the rest of it was just
sitting down talking and um they wanted
to do the rent to rent with us so yeah
so we're going to go into the details of
the house it's in Brighton right yeah
bright so how are you making four grand
a month from it when you don't own it uh
yes so we pay the rent and then we let
it as Airbnb and all these other
platforms how much do you pay to the
landlord uh 3 and a half thousand three
and a half Grand yeah three and half
Grand and you make four grand profit
yeah why don't they just rent it outs
well these landlords they had thought
about it to be fair but it's just too
much hassle and they've moved off abroad
so they're not really too fast how do
they feel knowing that you're making so
much profit from their house they're
completely fine with it they don't know
how much we're making but they're fine
with it they just want the circle of
they get their money I get my money and
just repeat sort of thing they're just
Happ guess their money is is guaranteed
it's the same every month they know what
they're getting your money might
fluctuate a little bit you've got to
work for it you've got to and and you've
invested a lot into your education of
how toly to run the business you know do
you know there's a lot of landlords that
see people doing rent to rent on their
property making a fortune and there's a
lot of landlords that at the end of the
contract at the end of the three four
five years whatever will then run it
themselves do you know how many of those
are successful nearly zero well um there
was a place we were going to take on and
the landlord actually decided to do it
themselves yeah I don't think they're
doing it anymore so no cuz if you don't
know what you're doing it's like any
business it's like if I decided to be a
gardener and got like you know trying to
do all the Hedge trimming and everything
like that I don't know how to I don't
know how to do it I'm not skilled not
competent not trained never been to
college never got work experience doing
it so I'm going to mess it up if I might
see my garden and think oh I could do
that it's the same when people see oh I
could put it on Airbnb it's not about
putting it on Airbnb it's about pricing
it rightly on all the different online
travel agents systemizing it correctly
having a stripe account collecting
payments collecting ID having all your
email sequences in place it's a business
yeah exactly and you know how to run the
business and that's why you're making
the money so have you got any other
deals since that big one uh yeah so we
put the keys up to A2 million house in
March so that'll be good that's going to
get about a grand T night is it the same
owner uh it's their best friends so yeah
that's the thing through one deal it
just repeats it does how much will that
make profit uh about 7 eight 7 eight
grand and this the one we've got at the
moment we're only getting about 50 60%
occupancy in the winter months wow so
hold on talk to me about this so on
average you're making four grand yeah
profit from the one that you've got
currently and that's not oh maybe we
might you've had that for how long how
many
months three four and even in the winter
months yeah that's winter and we're not
even fully booking it out yet so dam in
the summer it's going to be a lot more
mate yeah cuz you're near the beach yeah
exactly that must be a good feeling how
hard do you work now compared to how
hard you did work when you were a
gardener I don't really work much at all
now to be honest with you it's more just
chilling out at home probably look at my
phone a few times and just check how the
places go and sort of stuff and yeah and
you're making four grand a month and
you've got another deal that's going to
make you a lot more than that yeah a lot
more jeez so what would you say the
hardest thing is about getting into the
business uh for me it was my anxiety I
struggled to socialize and big crowd
sort of stuff so that first one pound
event for me was really pushing the boat
I went there thinking I'm not going to
pay for any courses I'm going to sit in
the back just be quiet and just see what
I can learn if I learned something I
learned something I'm not too fuss about
it and then when I was there I just
thought I've got to get the trading I
need the trading so I spoke to hustling
at the back and was like I need to do
the trade and sort of stuff and hustling
has been on Windows on a Wednesday yeah
exactly so um literally straight after
that signed up actually iby had to sit
on the phone and convince my mom to let
me uh sign up for the Academy so uh why
did why did I have to convince your mom
though uh well who was paying for it you
or your mom I was paying for it but my
mom looked after my money so we had a
house before remember be telling me
about this and um we lost loads of money
once we sold it cuz we were just young
stupid so I was like right you hold it
cuz I'm going to spend it on stupid
stuff and uh so she was holding it so
before I could pay for the Academy I had
to convince her to give me my money to
pay for it so um I remember literally
sitting on the phone with my mom and iby
on the there just saying like everything
good about the academy and stuff like
that and she let me take my money and
join the academy luckily enough wow wow
I mean it's your money but still she
given her Authority for me and make sure
I'm not spending it stupidly like I was
before how did you convince it then
because some people think that when you
invest in training and courses and
property education like oh you know it's
a scam or that that's some that
sometimes that's people's mentality
which is really funny because those are
the same people that will happily go to
university that if they're getting a
government back degree then it's like oh
that's okay you know and and it's funny
because people will go to UNI and
they'll be learning from somebody who's
on 30 40 Grand a year yeah exactly well
um for her it was more she wasn't too
fussed about me doing the property sort
of stuff it was more actually that
mentorship and that like onetoone and
help him with my anxiety and stuff like
that where she saw actually that would
benefit him anyway so even if he doesn't
become financially free at least I'm
getting that sort of Boos in confidence
and has he boosted your confidence yeah
definitely do you know what the best way
to boost your confidence is to make
money and just do stuff you're not
comfortable with well that's true but
when you see money hit in your bank I
mean damn it does make a difference it
does it does results yeah exactly how
have you changed in as a person over the
last what 6 12 months just more
confident I can just speak to people I'm
not all I ever want to speak to people
about this property to be honest with
you that's all I ever want to speak to
people about so um you become an addict
any any excuse to talk about that I'm
there but um yeah just being able to be
more confident speaking to people and
just pushing myself out of my comfort
zone sort of stuff and just more time
with my kids and stuff like that yeah
cuz I mean and also with a gardener cuz
my dad was a gardener it's quite
seasonal isn't it yeah so um we'd stop
in November until sort of February sort
of time I got time with my kids then but
you're so knackered from the year of
working anyway cuz it's just so what was
your annual salary as a gardener I know
I was probably making between one and
two grand a month profit sure but it was
I'm working that out as doing that sort
of stuff it wasn't worth it you just get
home you're knacked all you want to do
is just go to bed so with this property
then talk to me how did you find it and
how did you pitch the owner to give you
the property I literally messaged them
on open rent didn't even call them they
just said yeah we'd be open to that
saying about on open rent for anyone
that doesn't know is is what where you
can message L Lords directly right so
all the deals we've ever found have been
through open rent so you go on open
rent.co see a list of properties you see
this nice big house to describe the
property to me it's kind of like a
Spanish villa yeah it's got a hot tub in
the back Garden little Alex as well
which we're using as a fifth bedroom and
stuff like that yeah I just messaged
them on open rent was like this is what
we offer they messaged back saying yeah
we'd be open to that come view it
tomorrow when there the next day how did
you feel when they said that I was a bit
like why are these people with this
massive house giv it to me sort of thing
what did you say do you remember what
you said to them I just I just said what
we do so we um rent houses and fill them
with people on short stays and stuff
like that and we have like cleaners and
maintenance teams and stuff like that to
look after the place and which you did
have because you're on the academy and
we connected you to teams and helped you
get the knowledge and the training and
systems go you just needed a deal so uh
literally went to the viewing the next
day it was just before the dinner were
you scared not really cuz I was doing so
many viewings that week where we were
really like looking four deals but I was
there for about 3 hours just chatting to
them I probably spent about 5 minutes
walking around the house the rest of it
was just literally sitting down having a
conversation with them you always know
when you've got the deal cuz they say it
sounds too good to be
true they said that I thought I think
I've got this now so um yeah they were
really happy to do it but then what why
would they say it seems too good to be
true what would the benefit benefits for
them yeah so the benefits is they're
getting their rent each month and they
know we will look after it get it
cleaned any problems we fix sort of
stuff so for them it's like with them
moving abroad as well a normal tenant
wouldn't be able to they wouldn't be
able to manage it sort of thing yeah and
they'd have to pay management fees yeah
exactly which will be at least 10% so if
the rents how much are you paying three
and a half three and a half Grand that's
going to cost them 350 quid plus tenant
F fees plus they're going to have to pay
maintenance plus they're going to have
the fear of the tenant not paying the
rent and then travel all the way back to
sort it out from spting it's not and if
and if the tenant doesn't pay rent
they've then got to take them to court
whereas if you don't pay rent they can
come with a chainsaw yeah
exactly man but but but that's the thing
if if you're on a commercial lease
agreement with them then if you don't
pay rent to them we're out you're out
within seven days they can give you
seven days I think we've got it for two
weeks actually but two weeks and then
you aren't putting tenants in you're
putting guests in so it's a way that
everyone can get paid but there's no
tenants in the equation exactly which
means that there's no risk of tenants
not paying yeah exactly cuz if a guest
doesn't pay they're out with a chainsaw
in seconds and they pay in advance have
you had any guess to not pay never they
always pay in advance for us and stuff
so yeah what would you do if they didn't
pay and then they didn't check out and
you had another guest coming go kick
them out really as simple as that just
say you're not paying you're out we've
got same as a hotel yeah well we've got
an electric gate at the front as well so
if they go out we can just lock it for
and change the code and they can't come
back in so they said the cleaners take
the stuff but it's never happened
because it never would because for some
reason tenants feel like some not all
tenants some tenants feel like oh they
have a right to not pay rent that is
their home whereas when you're a guest
and you're hiring the home yeah you're
hiring it you're a guest it's a
different they look after a lot more as
what I find do you reckon think have you
had parties and stuff uh we did have one
bad guest where um it was book for four
people and another four people turned up
I just made them pay the fee get extra
guest fee and and did you have their
card details on fire yeah card details
ID and stuff like that so it was W
really worried that's the thing with if
you're uneducated and you rent your
property on an Airbnb and you get a
guest trashing it having parties you
don't know what to do charge them yeah
you can because you know how to do it
because you take their car dets up front
you have their ID everything like that
but unless you got those systems in
place then then what then you're screwed
yeah but a normal tenant could probably
thr parties and you wouldn't even know I
think the difference is between a normal
t and a guest is with a with a guest
because they're nor in there for a short
time maybe a few days or or a week or so
you got the cleaners constantly going in
and making sure that it's doing
inventories cleaning it whereas with a
normal tenant you might do an inspection
every six months yeah so you might have
come after six months and go holy moly
what's happened so you're much more on
it aren't you yeah definitely um so
how's your relationship going with the
owner uh yeah it's going really well
actually um they've got best friends who
also want to give them our play their
place to us the second2 million P House
2 million pound house so so we're
getting that how much rent are you
paying for that 7 Grand jeez it's a lot
but we're charging about a grand T night
for that yeah and it's we're going to do
some charity work with it as well cuz
it's on the sea front and it's got
disabled access like lifts and
everything like that so we're going to
try give do like giveaways and stuff to
like someone disabled in their family
and stuff and cool that sort of stuff
and then you'll be able to stay there
yourself occasionally from time I can't
wait for that it's got a swimming pool
and everything something so you just
you've just massively upgraded your life
in the last six months yeah absolutely
um what does your mom think about your
success uh yeah she's happy with it
she's just kind of just seeing how it
goes at the moment to be honest with you
because it still is early so it's just
sure let's just see sort of what you say
at first they're going to say don't do
it then it's like well we'll see and
then that sort at first it's don't do it
then it's okay but be careful be careful
and then it's okay well we'll see and
then it's well money isn't
everything but mve your mom I'm sure it
won't be because she loves you and
she'll be happy to see you successful
what's been the hardest bit about the
whole business probably just structuring
it and sort of stuff making sure
everything's in place i' struggled with
that a bit at the start we kind of that
first property we'll go back to that the
one that it all messed up so talk to me
what happened exactly and why did you
end up having to give the keys back yeah
so well I mean we took it on cuz it was
the first deal we kind of rushed into it
we really like the place the landlord
said to us there's no restrictions in
the head Le he can't see anything turns
out they've worded it quite awkwardly so
you can't to the average person you're
not going to know they're not allow in
short stays so um we got letters like a
few months later saying this isn't
allowed so on and so on um from who from
the head leas from the freeholders freeh
holders yeah really like the management
company and stuff some we're not allowed
to be doing it and stuff like that so
basically for anyone that doesn't know
what you're talking about if you own an
apartment the apartment is owned by you
but you don't own the communal space the
land that's the Freeholder yeah and
there's an agreement between the
Freeholder and the lease holder and in
that agreement
which is a head leas sometimes there can
be restrictions that say in this
apartment you cannot allow people on
short stat and like I said they worded
it quite cleverly so to the average
person vague and they were literally
threatening legal action everything like
that saying the last person that did
this got charged £16,000 and stuff like
that so you have an agreement with the
owner of the property which is fine but
the owner of the property has an
agreement with the freeh owner which is
not fine which say they can't do it so
what were the lessons that you learn
from that to prevent that ever happening
to anyone ever again well firstly check
the lease every time we take on a place
now with an apartment we'll look for the
lease but um you asked the landlord to
provide you copy of the lease do you
yeah we'll look at it this time last
time we didn't look at it we just took
his word for IT thing um but we don't
really have to worry about it too much
now cuz we're taking on houses so there
is no restrictions like that so yeah so
with Apartments another thing is if
you're get in an apartment and you don't
know if there's a head Le restriction on
some issue it's really important that
the agreement between you and the
landlord says that if the landlord
hasn't been upfront about anything and
as a result you end up having to
terminate the agreement and if it's the
landlord's fault effectively which in
this case it was it should say in the
contract that the landlord has to
reimburse any setup costs that you put
into the deal meaning you will lose no
money did you have that agreement we did
have that but I mean we when we had to
give it back we were breaking even on
how much we put in and stuff like that
so we just it wasn't worth the hassle of
maybe going back and forth aring with
him to reburst I was just like yeah
let's just give it back you you didn't
lose financially you lost a bit of time
yeah you just took the hit so it was
just like yeah let's just give it back
then but these are all things that need
to be drawn up properly with with rent
to rents yeah definitely another thing
is if you've got rent to rent how long
is your lease with your current landlord
so this one is 12 months and then after
that we're going to focus on taking on
as the lease option sure so you got 12
months you get to know them they get to
know you typically it's three years but
we've done 12 months then lease option
and and how will the contract then
change what will happen with the lease
option uh yeah we'll just negotiate the
lease option the price we're going to
pay and just go for all that sort of
stuff so what is the least option uh
basically it's kind of like you do with
a car where you buy in a few years time
for the price now yeah for the price now
right so you agree a price now and then
pay later yeah sure so so least option
on on a house in Brighton would be we'll
continue paying you three and a half
Grand a month but then in 5 years we'll
buy it we'll buy it for a million quid
or whatever whatever the price is and at
the end of the term you then know you've
got the option to buy it for a million
so you're saving up the money you're
making sure the property's kept really
good condition but then from the owner's
perspective they know they've got a nice
person paying the rent who's got an
incentive to keep and they've got time
to then not focus on the capital gains
tax they didn't really want have to pay
that straight away as well so it was
just doing that sort of stuff which is a
really good point because also as well
if they've got a lot of property If a
landlord owns lots of properties and
they want to sell the portfolio if you
sell your whole portfolio all in Mong go
as you mentioned you get blasted with
capital gains tax yeah whereas if you
just sell one property a year yeah you
can stagger it and then it massively
decreases the amount of capital gains
tax that you pay so that makes sense so
what have been the biggest lessons then
that you've learned lessons just check
the head leas restrictions yeah that's a
big if I'm honest with you there's not
really been many lessons I've learned to
be honest with you it's just push
yourself really and just go out there
and do it put everything into it I mean
with these big places we're taking
massive risk yeah but it's kind of like
high risk High reward is it worth it
yeah if it pays Works off just you may
as well so how are you financing this
next property because presumably if
you've got pay 7even eight grand a month
rent then you've also got to pay up
front rent maybe a deposit you've also
got bits and Bobs Furniture like how you
find so uh a lot of the furniture
they're going to leave us which happened
with this place we've got at the moment
as well are you paying um deposit no so
we're going to pay three months up front
rent instead which we did with this one
it's a lot of money up front but
actually you're paying that rent anyway
so it just gives you time to kind of
chit out when you're getting it ready
and not thinking we've got to get people
in here now to pay for the rent next
month exactly so um yeah we did that
with the first one and we thought out no
deposit Furniture in place yeah three
months rent but then you're going to get
that you're going to start getting
bookings in straight away yeah exactly
we've already got booking for over a
grand so what is the vision then so what
you're doing this thing you're renting
houses you're renting for a high amount
making good money what's the end goal
now next year we're going to start
looking at BR sort of projects and
moving on to that sort of stuff CU these
two kind of cover us financially we
don't you say us what do you mean you me
and my partner sorry you and your
partner yeah so they kind of cover us so
we don't really need to take any more on
so we're just going to focus on owning
stuff now and yeah what does your
partner think about what you've done
yeah she loves it she happy yeah she's
happy with it how's life changed just
more time if I'm honest with you that
was the main thing just get more time
sort stuff I've not really started
upgrading my life yet with buying stuff
it's more just spend some time with the
kids and stuff like that when they young
how's it been working on the academy
I've loved it every minute of it yeah
I've absolutely loved it what would you
say to somebody that was thinking about
investing in property training getting
in the community to I say to everyone
just do it sign up for the Academy
because it is the best thing I've ever
done well I can't wait to see your next
property I'll come down as I said and
I'll see in person draw some lessons
thanks for coming on the show thank you
for having what was it that made you
agree to come on winners on a Wednesday
were you nervous oh crap at it really
why the gain the anxiety and stuff like
that so yeah it's always pushing that
comfort zone sort of thing this is a big
thing for me to do but you've got to do
it sort of thing so are you an extrovert
or an introvert introvert definitely to
be honest with you i' like to stay quiet
just observe the room sort of stuff and
keep to myself a bit interesting but the
Academy's definitely changed that a bit
I do try to socialize a lot more now
well dude real congrats thanks so much
for coming on and I think that people
will have learned a lot so big my friend
thanks Max